STEPHANIE WONG: It's officially
week one of Google Cloud Next
OnAir, which means we're
focusing on industry insights.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Next OnAir officially
begins tomorrow
at 9:00 AM Pacific time
with Thomas Kurian's opening
keynote.
If you'd like to hear
the CEO of Google Cloud
share his insight
on how businesses
can leverage Google
Cloud technology,
then be sure to add
this to your playlist.
After that, week one is all
about industry insights,
meaning we wanted to spend the
first week emphasizing what
you can do with Google Cloud.
For that, we've got eight
industry spotlights--
financial services, health
care and life sciences, gaming,
manufacturing, media and
entertainment, public sector,
retail, and telecommunications.
You can hear directly
from organizations
that have built clever solutions
with a little help from Google
Cloud.
One session that I'm
particularly excited about
is "Reimagining Public
Sector in the COVID-19 Era."
Pretty much everyone has to plan
around legacy systems, which
is why I love the idea of
learning how government
and education
institutions adapted when
faced with a global pandemic.
Roberta Reardon, the New
York State Department
of Labor Commissioner,
will join Mike Daniels,
our VP of Global Public
Sector, in what's
sure to be an
interesting session.
So be sure to add
it to your playlist.
And don't forget
to go exploring.
We've done our best to bring
all the aspects of a conference
floor into this digital event.
So be sure to check out
the Digital Showcase, where
you can find video demos of
how Google Cloud tools can
help solve the various business
challenges you may be facing.
We've also got a collection
of interactive demos,
and even several
learning opportunities,
all launching tomorrow.
So have fun wandering
around the website.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the links in
the video description.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.